author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight great to see mark by the way we
had a gun registry up in Canada yeah
that was a complete fiasco yeah it
turned out to be it got completely
infected with inaccurate information and
I think the Canadian Taxpayers wound up
spending $600 per gun registration
because it became just another pointless
inaccurate government boondoggle but why
is it that the people look I mean there
are a lot of reasons these things happen
and ultimately they're the fault of the
guy who does it the guy who pulls the
trigger but if government is telling you
we can keep you safe you have no right
to protect yourself we're going to
protect you and then they don't and then
they won't admit that they did and then
they persist in trying to prevent you
from protecting yourself doesn't that
suggest that maybe something's not on
the level here yes and I think actually
this gets to the heart of it if you were
to look at this this school Cobb
so-called if he if his behavior is as
reported is a very good example of what
happens when you massively expand law
enforcement the proportion of bad police
the the police who let you down will
increase and it will eventually be like
the TSA when you go to the conveyor belt
and get your rotate your shoes off and
there's nine people standing around but
how many of them would actually respond
effectively in a bad situation
that's the first problem the second
problem is that if you were serious
about gun control you'd have to change
the minds of tens of millions of
American law-abiding American settlers
so you would not stage the spectacle
that CNN stage last night which bought
back members to me of the Paul Wellstone
funeral 15 years ago you remember he
died in a plane crash very sad they held
a funeral and turned it into an ugly
partisan political reality to speech
speaking as it's being as a foreigner
you know Americans
the gun private gun ownership is central
to Americans sense of themselves in a
way that it is not to Australians for
example and that to change that requires
calm thoughtful rational debate rather
than emotional exhibitionism of the kind
on display last night I think you made
the key point right there which is you
need to convince people you can't change
hundreds of years of law and custom
simply by Fiat or screaming or
threatening people in a democracy you
have to bring people along with you you
have to not compel them but convince
them and the left doesn't seem
interested in that at all no and I think
this is this is actually where it's
going well I would say for example that
if you look at Germany and Scandinavia
where police chiefs tell women that it's
not safe to go out alone at night since
they let all the refugees into the
country you have declining social trust
which is likely to move Europeans back
towards a self defense model now you
have declining declining social trust is
one of the phenomena of our times here
in America and whenever and when people
look at that incompetent and weaselly
sheriff last night battering Dana lash
who's a private citizen because she
wants to know why he didn't act on any
of those 39 complaints people are not
willing to mortgage their self-defense
rights to the government and not a
government as inept as all levels of
proof whether it's school district
Sheriff or federal all go levels of
government failed in Florida that's
exactly right
if you're telling me I can't defend
myself you're gonna protect me you
better prove you can and they're not
mark that is really deep and smart thank
you as always